you've done an absolutely stunning job
here you didn't just get it over the
line you blew the doors off
the first picture here since 1998 an
amazing amazing set of results I didn't
doubt it when I saw the energy and the
commitment and the case that we were
making but what a fantastic result here
in Medway and we're having fantastic
results across the country Plymouth what
a night they've had in Plymouth and then
Stoke
and up to Middlesbrough all the places
that we need to win the Battlegrounds
and make no mistake we are on course for
a labor majority at the next general
election
about the cost of living and we had a
positive case to make we understood what
it's like not to be able to make ends
meet and we said what we would do to
help people with their everyday bills
and the government the prime minister
said nothing and that's because they're
the problem not the solution right
and what we've shown together is that we
can make change we've changed our party
we've won the trust and confidence of
Voters and now we can go on to change
our country so change is possible a
better Britain is possible well done to
all of you fantastic morning thank you
so much